So welcome to Unit Five. The main topic for this
unit is trying to understand the cost of running programs. So
far, we haven't really worried about this. We've been very happy
to write code. If we get the correct result, that's a
great thing. But once we start making programs bigger, worrying
about programs that do more things, running on larger inputs, we
have to start thinking about the cost of running our programs.
And this question of what it costs to evaluate an execution
is a very important problem in computer science. In some
sense, it's one of the most fundamental problems. Many people
spend their whole careers working on this. And it's a
problem called Algorithm Analysis. I haven't yet explained what an
algorithm is. But you've actually written many of them already.
So an algorithm is a procedure that always finishes. A
procedure is just a well-define sequence of steps. It has
to be defined precisely enough that it could be executed mechanically.
So to be a procedure, it has to be something
that can be executed without any thought. And we're mostly interested
in procedures that can be executed by computers. But the
important part of what makes it a procedure is that the
steps are very precisely defined and don't require any thought
to execute. To be an algorithm, it has to always finish,
and we've pointed out already that this is a very tough
problem to figure out whether a program will finish. In general,
it's not possible to answer that question, but for many specific
programs it is, and in order for a program to be an
algorithm, we have to know that it always finishes, and it always
produces a correct result. So once we have an algorithm, well, we
know we have a well-defined sequence of steps, so we can reason
about what will happen on any input, and we know that we
will always finish and always produce the correct result. So then we
can think about what the cost is of executing that algorithm on
some input. So how should we think about cost?
And the way computer scientists think about cost is
quite different from how most people think about cost.
So if you're normally thinking about cost, well, if
you've got a specific object, let's say, you've got
a cool car. This is supposed to be a
cool car. It doesn't quite look like a cool
car, and it's got a cost associated with it.
Let's say, that's a $25,000 car, and you have some
other car. So you have one car, it's got a
particular cost, that's what it costs you get that car.
You could another car that would be smaller and green, and
let's say that car costs $10,000. And when we think
about the cost of things normally, we have very specific things,
and they have specific costs. And we know that the
red car costs $25,000; the green car costs $10,000; the red
car costs more than the green car. We
just need to compare those costs. So when we
think about the cost of algorithms, we don't
have a specific execution in mind usually. What we
want to understand is how the cost depends on
input. So we might have two different algorithms. Let's
say this is algorithm one, and we have a
second algorithm that solves the same problem. And both
of these are algorithms that take inputs and produce output.
And if we want to decide which algorithm is better, well, we
don't have a specific cost for the algorithm the way we
do for the cars. And we can say the red car
costs more than the green car. The cost depends on the
actual input that we run the algorithm on, so it might
be the case for some inputs algorithm one is faster, and
for other inputs, algorithm two is faster, and I should label
this algorithm two. So what we need to understand is how
the cost of executing the algorithm depends on the input. We
don't want to do that for every specific input, right, if we
had to do that for every input, well, we might as
well just run it on the input and see what it costs.
What we want to do is be able to predict this without
actually having to run on on every input. Normally, there isn't that
much that matters about this specific input. The main thing that's going to
matter about the input is the size of the input. That's not
always the case, and we'll see examples where other properties
of the input matter, but the primary way that we talk
about cost in computer Science is based on the size
of the input. As the size of inc, input increases, how
does the cost to evaluate the procedure increase? So cost
ultimately always comes down to money. And when it comes down
to money, well, what are the things that cost money when
we execute algorithms? And the main things that costs money are
the time it takes to finish. If we get an answer
more quickly, well, we've spent less time on it, and we
can also rent computers by the time to execute. There are
lots of cloud computing services now that will give you a processor
of a certain power for a certain amount of time, for
a certain number of cents per hour. So time really is money.
So we don't need to turn our cost estimates into money
because we don't necessarily know how much our computing cost will be.
But if we can understand the time it takes to execute, that
will give us a good sense of the cost. The other main
cost is often memory. So, if we know that we need a
certain amount of memory to be able to execute our algorithms, well,
that tells us something about the size of computer we need and
how expensive that's going to be. So, we don't usually talk about cost
in terms of dollars when we analyze a logarithms, we're talking about
cost in terms of time and memory. But those things in real
implementations end up being cost in terms of
dollars. So we're mostly going to focus on measuring time,
and time is usually the most important cost
of running an algorithm. Memory is often another consideration.